michael myers the most notorious
resident of haddonfield illinois is back
in halloween kills here are some of the
biggest unanswered questions from the
second installment of david gordon green
slasher trilogy michael myers appears to
break free from the bonds of mortality
and halloween kills something teased by
lori strode
the more he kills
the more he transcends
a theory appears to be correct this guy
simply will not die throughout the 105
minute run time of halloween kills
michael walks out of laurie's burning
house seemingly unharmed only to be
repeatedly beaten stabbed and shot by
the residents of haddonfield during the
movie's climax an angry mob led by tommy
doyle swarms him in an attempt to kill
him in a brutal act of vigilante
violence and yet as a credit's role
michael is still standing can he
actually be killed throughout the 12
films in the halloween franchise michael
has endured many life-threatening
injuries and has never been successfully
taken out
surely he isn't human at least not
anymore so there must be some
explanation as to how he can continue to
survive being injured repeatedly without
any repercussions michael's ability to
survive anything in green's contained
halloween trilogy appears to echo a
separate halloween franchise movie
1995's halloween the curse of michael
myers in that movie as a child michael
was cursed by an ancient druidic group
called the cult of thorne giving him
supernatural abilities beyond those of
mortal men green's films have yet to
establish anything quite this
supernatural but with one movie left
will an otherworldly deus ex machina be
revealed as a reason for michael's
inability to die
it has been suggested that michael's
purpose throughout the halloween
franchise is to hunt and murder lori
strode but it becomes clear in halloween
kills this may not entirely be true
laurie and her daughter karen think
michael is coming to the hospital to
finish laurie off but he never appears
later on the critically injured officer
hawkins reveals from his hospital bed
that michael's killing spree could
likely be related to his deep-seated
need to return to his childhood home the
place where it all began lani elam
another survivor of michael's 1978
rampage separately deduces this as he
maps out the path the killer is taking
back to the old maya's home on lampkin
lane at the end of halloween kills
michael goes back upstairs where as a
child he used to look out the window as
he stands in the spots where he made his
first kill it's unclear if this is what
he truly wants is michael still just a
purely evil entity he was compelled to
kill or does coming home mean he will
relent for the first time in his life
in 2018's halloween and halloween kills
karen strode becomes a symbol of a
strong female who survives michael's
reign she protects her mother and
daughter alison from michael's killer
streak but unfortunately karen's future
in the next film has a huge question
mark looming over it the final act of
halloween kills includes an intense
scene between michael and alison in the
lampkin lane house after he brutally
murders her boyfriend cameron and then
stabs her and throws her down the stairs
as alison eggs on michael to kill her
karen comes up behind him and stabs him
in the back she takes his mask off and
as he gets back up she lures him to
follow her
set up as a trap michael sees his mask
lying in the empty street and as he
picks it up a large group of townspeople
circle him beat him mercilessly and even
shoot him michael survives his group
attack and returns to his childhood home
he goes up to the room once occupied by
his sister and creeps up behind karen
who believes she is alone and tries to
regain some calm michael begins stabbing
her and viewers only see her terrified
reaction will karen continue to fight
back or has michael myers claimed
another victim
the fate of alison laurie's
granddaughter is still unknown at the
end of halloween kills in the movie's
final act alison cameron and cameron's
dad lonnie drive to michael mayer's
childhood home michael quickly
dispatches lonnie and cameron and alison
watches her boyfriend die following a
failed attempt to save him after she has
thrown down a flight of stairs her leg
is badly injured and as a result she's a
sitting duck for michael as he
approaches her she dares him to kill her
he doesn't have the chance to fulfill
her demand because karen interrupts and
attacks him as the two fight allison can
only watch and able to fight back in the
last moments of halloween kills michael
appears in his sister's bedroom where
karen is standing while alison remains
downstairs being attended to by first
responders given the fact that this
seemingly unkillable masked murderer is
just one floor above she's not exactly
out of harm's way michael's fixation on
the strode bloodline is so strong that
it's quite possible alison will end up
in his crosshairs once he finishes
dealing with karen however taking
allison off the board would be
disappointing considering her
development into a tougher than tough
final girl has been so compelling to
watch
we're gonna head him down and we're
gonna put an end to this
in 1978 the halloween movie franchise
began with lori strode and michael myers
with one movie left in david gordon
green's branch of this film series it
feels like we could see the story end
with lori and michael too throughout
halloween kills lori repeatedly tries to
leave haddonfield memorial hospital
despite her severely weakened physical
state she has spent decades convincing
herself that only she can kill michael
as if their fates are inextricably
linked and thus only she can make the
final blow her mindset is understandable
especially considering how laser-focused
she was on killing michael in 2018's
halloween which reveals she spent 40
years training herself to defend against
another attack from michael after
surviving his first attempt on her life
with michael and laurie still alive and
mobile as her credit's role in halloween
kills it seems halloween ends will turn
its gaze toward this pairing
thematically it would make sense that
laurie and michael's fates are tied
together as a director and co-writer
green appears to be intent on telling a
halloween story that focuses on the
impact cycles of violence and trauma can
have on multiple generations lori and
her family are caught in a new cycle one
that echoes the events of 1978 but
what's different this time around is
that they are intent on breaking it with
karen and alison failing to do away with
michael it seems the only person left to
face to shape is laurie bringing
everything full circle as the original
final girl and her enemy prepare for one
final showdown
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite slasher movies are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
you